Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July 14th,
2014.
Oh my God.
You guys.
Where is this summer going,
going?
Um,
I can't wait for the winter.
I like the winter.
I enjoy it.
Okay.
I'm a pasty fucked.
There's nothing the summer offers nothing for me.
Okay.
Either I'm outside with that.
Look on my face.
You know that little [inaudible] joy,
whatever the fuck you call it,
when it's got that look on his face,
like it's gone.
Ooh.
You know that,
that face,
what is it called?
The emoji where it's like,
that's the look I have on my fucking face when I walk around between May and
August.
And uh,
you know,
I'm telling you right now,
all those theories about what's going to kill off redheads,
recessive genes and it's going to be global warming.
That's what it's going to be.
Cause I got to tell you if these summers get any hotter,
right?
I've been in new,
I'm in New York City right now.
Uh,
I got a benefit tonight and tomorrow out in Brooklyn.
And,
um,
you know,
it's a benefit,
that type of shit.
Couldn't be doing that out there.
I don't know what it is.
All right.
I fucking just woke up and I got to knock this thing out because I got shit to
do today.
And uh,
I got to tell you,
I haven't been here in New York in a while and it's been,
uh,
it's definitely been cool to be back here,
but I gotta tell you,
this city just beats the shit out of you.
I was returning this rental car this morning,
you know,
literally it was like fucking nine streets up in two blocks over.
That took me a good 40 minutes.
I was trying to find a gas station,
right?
I said to the lady in my phone,
you know,
where's the gas station?
She's like,
there's the gas station right down the street.
Right?
So I follow her,
I go all the way down there and there's a fucking,
you know,
I dunno.
I Dunno what they're doing.
This scrubbing out the gas tanks,
so that thing's screwed.
So then I asked the lady again,
she's like,
dad,
it's over 15.
Right near you.
So I click on the closest dot.
I drive to that one.
That one,
it takes me like another 15 minutes to get to.
I get to that one.
It's got a fence around it and oh,
it was red faced going through the roof of his rental care.
I did not handle it like an adult whatsoever.
I just kept acting like a big baby.
Big Stupid.
Like if they had like adult size pacifiers,
somebody should have just shoved one right in my mouth.
Slapped me on my fucking hand and said,
hey,
you know,
like my dad used to write no pacifier.
He always said cool it or he snapped really loud just like that.
We all just stopped worrying that he's going to kick the shit out of us.
And he never did.
Never laid a hand on us.
But how loud is snap was you could only imagine his fucking fist.
So you shut up,
you shut the fuck up because back in the day when you could discipline kids,
right?
You could beat the shit out of him,
right in public and people would walk by.
That would be it.
So your father's threats were actually something serious.
I'll tell you this whole generation of kids,
they're wide open for a fucking ass kick and the way they walked down the street
with their faces in the phone,
you could upper cut them right through their phone,
right into their face,
be lovely.
And I think it would do this generation,
they could do them a bit of good cause I'm a crabby old guy and I liked the way
things yo still big.
Um,
anyways,
so I'm walking down the streets out here in New York and the amount of people of
all ages just muttering to themselves and how they can make my rent and I
fucking roommate moved out.
I don't know what the fuck they're talking about.
You know,
do I got HPV right.
I don't know what they're pitching about.
And I don't know if they're more crazier than other cities because I think what
it is in this city,
you can't hide in your fucking car.
You know,
out in La,
I can fucking be talking to my hour.
I run in my God Damn Yap and somebody pulls up next to me and looks over at me
and I can seamlessly go from my own psycho shadow with myself to pretending I'm
singing with the radio.
And I did and when I do,
they know and the lights go down the thing.
Hi,
how are you?
Just singing to the radio that isn't on,
that's fucking stupid journey song has been in my head for three days and I hope
it's now in yours because I'm taking all you fuckers down with me and this goes
somewhere with the band.
I've heard this song like a thousand times,
but I don't know the lyrics because it fucking sucks.
Um,
how many of those bands are there out there where you're like a radio fan?
Like you know all the lyrics like say Billy Joel,
I don't own one album.
That,
that bug eyed psycho.
Yeah,
you're giving me lots of laughs today.
Cracking up.
Yeah.
Do you know I used to,
I couldn't stand him back in the day.
Nia when he did that stupid,
the uptown girl song making it seem like he was this bad ass when the wrong side
of the tracks.
I remember that like,
what is she doing with me?
Oh,
I'm a bad ass little bug eyed Jewish kid playing a piano.
Keep him away from my children.
And I was like,
why is he acting like he's this maniac?
And then 40 years later he's getting hammered,
driving his car through the front of people's houses.
And I was like,
you know what I,
Oh,
Billy Joel and apology apology.
Not only was I 100% wrong,
I want to drink with that maniac.
How much fun would he be to drink with?
He could talk about what it was like to bang a supermodel and then just sit down
and start playing some tunes and he's got all those songs in three four which
are your greatest thing when you're drunk,
right?
Except for piano man,
that song,
I never liked that song.
The way people sway back and forth,
Yadda da Da da,
do BD Ibew.
And I said,
man,
what are you doing here?
Oh,
shut up.
It's like if Anthony Bordain played the piano,
you know,
he's always trying to make his fucking going out to get a hotdog.
So fucking artsy and what's going on?
What's going on with society.
It's like just shove whatever you're talking about in your face and let me know
if it's good.
All righty.
And what are you doing?
And um,
so anyways,
yeah.
So I'm here in New York are chomping at the bit.
I've wanted to do stand up the last couple of nights,
but my wife won't let me.
She says,
Hey,
you're going to go out and you're going to buy me some shoes,
buddy.
We haven't been into one single store,
so fuck you.
What are you talking about?
No,
I've just been a little bit lazy.
I've been waking up every morning,
boop,
boop.
And I were walking down the street.
I've been,
uh,
I've be going over the Brooklyn Bridge every single day.
That's been my workout.
And then I find some scaffolding and I got wet and I conk out at four,
and then I fucking dropped to the fucking ground and I turn around this some cab
driver laughing at me,
right with his yellow stained white button down shirt that he's probably been
wearing for the last 15 hours of his shift looking at me like,
Oh gee,
I would love to do some pull ups on scaffolding other than than climb.
Instead of climbing up there and actually working on it,
we're talking about white privilege here today on the podcast.
Everybody,
um,
where one part where one person sees slave labor.
I see a gym.
I see a free gym.
Isn't that terrible?
And he was just shaking her head,
I thought you were getting out of here.
I don't like your stylist running shoes.
When did you buy him?
Because of the orange shoelaces.
I'm like,
what that says about me?
Yeah,
you are.
You look cute today.
Yeah.
See I did that and insulted the shit out of everybody and you end with something
nice and then there you go.
Please try not to drop things.
Um,
all right.
What are we going to talk about this whole week,
this week?
Um,
all right,
let's,
let's get it over with.
Shut up.
Um,
let's get this over with Lebron James went back to Cleveland.
I'll tell you right now.
I don't think I've ever been so fucking disappointed in a city.
You know,
like,
you remember when Lebron left you the first time?
Do you remember how devastated you were or how you cried and threw all his
Lebron shit out in your front lawn?
You lit it on fire like some checks had been cheated on.
You.
Remember that shit?
Of course you'd do was only four years ago and I didn't,
I didn't judge you.
There's no way that you knew what he was,
but now you know,
and what did you do?
You let them back in.
You got back into this relationship with them like Pamela Anderson back in the
day,
getting back with Tommy Lee,
right?
Like he wasn't going to have batted that.
Being a demand at the dome like that wasn't going to fucking happen again.
And Jesus Christ,
fucking Cleveland.
Do you really think that this guy's going to stick around?
How long do you think he's going to be there before he realizes he's in
Cleveland again and he's going to start checking out some of the other hot
chicks around the leak?
Maybe Chicago.
What about La?
They'd done if they hoard them out themselves out enough that their franchise
Twat is just hanging down to their ankles that nobody loved.
Jesus built.
Nobody wants to go out there anymore.
I don't know.
Hey Bill,
what are you coming down and Cleveland floor?
We haven't won a championship forever.
Fuck you Cleveland.
You bunch of fucking babies.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Who's been giving you shit?
Nobody.
Nobody chance the fucking year,
1948 nobody does.
You don't have any curse.
You don't have anything.
All right.
All you had to do was build art of fucking stadium,
but you wouldn't do it.
You wouldn't build a football stadium,
but you've built a fucking rock and roll hall of fame so they could hang
Brittany Spears jumpsuit next to Mick Jagger's.
These are your priorities.
And as a sports fan,
I'm supposed to feel bad for you.
My heart's supposed to warm.
When this guy who cheated on you with the Miami Heat went down there and he got
the fucking professional herps right now.
He's coming back to give it to you when you drop into your fucking knees,
taking your fucking burned up.
But I,
Lebron Jersey,
audio,
little wastepaper basket,
whatever the fuck you have next to your desk.
Okay.
Um,
I'm fucking with you guys.
Hey,
I'm happy for you.
He came back.
I hope you guys want to champion chip.
As long as the Lakers don't win,
I'm happy.
I'm excited.
Does I don't like how,
you know I've talked about it before while they claim won more championships
than they should.
Who's getting,
no,
I know the pass and the Celtics.
Nobody wants to come play for the Celtics.
It's fucking,
it kills me.
You know,
part of it isn't our problem.
It's the weather.
All right,
this is the op Kate,
look,
you look at the NBA,
what is it like 91% African American.
Okay.
So it usually comes down to where do you want to play.
So let's say the Celtics are bidding on the same free agent as the Lakers,
right?
So these are the options.
I think I've said this before,
there are options.
You want to come to Boston where it's cold and the racism is off the chats?
Or would you like to play in la where it's warm?
There's,
there's,
there's celebrity as to bang and the racism is off the chat.
Either way,
you're not going to like the police force.
You know what?
The weather's nice.
I mean,
we can't,
we can't compete with that fucking over.
Um,
I'm just fucking with you.
Cleveland guys ain't,
by the way,
I'm sick of every fucking thing being described as a rant.
Do you know last week I was,
I was just talking about the Dj scene in Vegas,
just talking about,
but the thing now is you've,
you,
if you talk about something
for like more than like two minutes,
all of a sudden it's,
it's called a rant.
Like to me,
isn't rant like short for ranting and raving.
So I should have been lazy.
Fucking Tara tables.
I mean that,
that is ranting,
right?
We just fucking talking about something.
I don't know.
I've never looked the word up,
but ranting and also heckling.
Those are the two things that drive me nuts when they say the comedian heckled
the crowd,
the comedian cannot heckle the crowd.
The crowd is not giving a performance that can be interrupted.
Do you understand that
Jesus?
Um,
anyways,
so what else?
What else happened in,
so anyways,
he's back.
Okay.
Lebron James is back in Cleveland.
You know it's funny,
I thought was hilarious.
Was An uh,
Miami.
They had a picture of the big three in somebody like spray painted over Lebron's
face.
It's like go fuck yourself.
You know what I mean?
He was never yours.
How did you get the Guy?
I hate when fans do that.
That was like when Celtics fans were mad.
When Ray Allen went down to the fucking heat.
It's like he wasn't ours.
He wasn't ours.
All right.
He came in,
he came,
we got him off the meat market.
You can't expect the guy not to do that again.
The guy is just super sonic.
Okay.
Who's closing out his career with the Celtics and the heat if he hasn't already
retired,
you can't get mad about that.
Alright.
What the fuck?
Kind of heat fan.
Fucking pates over Lebron's face.
The guy brought you to the finals four years in a row and you won two
championships.
What's the problem?
I could see if Dwayne Wade left.
Um,
why am I talking about this sport?
I know nothing about.
This is the fucking annoy you guys.
How about that?
Um,
all right.
The war I United States rejoices as the World Cup ends.
Jesus Christ.
But I got to say somebody finally got a real injury.
That guy on Brazil actually broke a vertebrae.
It's always terrifying.
Thank God he's all right.
You know,
as far as broken vertebraes go,
at least there was no nerve damage as far as I know.
So that's a good thing.
And uh,
how about the crowds,
man?
How about the Germans?
Not fucking around what they did to Brazil?
That was unbelievable.
That was a football game.
That would have been like,
I don't know how many times is seven going to 91 I have no fucking idea what a
[inaudible] 70,
77 84 13 that'd be like scoring 13 fucking touch stouts.
Yeah,
that was the game.
You know what kills me is I missed that game.
I actually,
I take that,
I'm on the road right now.
As I mentioned,
I'm going to watch it when I get back because that is the soccer game.
Every person in the United States has wanted to see forever to have one team
score seven goals or both of them score seven combined for a four to three games
for the love of fucking Christ.
You know,
I'm fucking with you guys.
I actually,
uh,
I watched the final,
I watched it,
uh,
at Paul versus house man.
We had a great time and uh,
yeah,
and he was laughing.
He was into it.
He's going down,
he's going to soccer is the shit.
And we were talking about this stuff.
I swear to God,
we fucked up so bad.
What we should've done was we should have recorded our audio watching that game.
So people in Europe and all around the world could enjoy how fucking ignorant we
are of the Goddamn sport.
Just classic lines like,
Dude,
do you want to stand like how much the world cares about this?
We,
we even recognize how fucking stupid we sounded,
but I got to get this clip.
If anybody can find it
at the end of the game
when Germany one,
and unfortunately Argentine,
a loss,
my condolences out to them.
I actually like both countries.
You know what I mean?
And I think they kind of like each other,
you know,
if you know what I mean.
For those of you who read about the fallout after World War II,
um,
the,
uh,
at the end of the game,
when they would go in through the crowd and they were showing the German fans,
you know,
freaking out,
is there anything scarier than a fucking angry German family?
MMM.
When they showed the Argentinian,
whatever the fuck you call them,
uh,
okay.
They cut to this guy and I swear to God,
remember that joke that mean Versie we're doing where we pretended like we were
crying.
Like,
you know,
I'm gonna have such a good time in New York like that.
There was a guy in the crowd,
he literally looked like that's how he was crying.
The Guy,
he was in his fifties he had one of those hats on,
you know,
from back in the fifties and sixties when married guys would join a men's club.
They had to get away from their wives that was getting who they want him to get
blown on,
all weather carpet and some sort of one floor ranch building down the street.
And they'd put that little hat on with the Tassel on the side.
He was wearing one of those and they cut to him and he was,
he was fucking blubbering.
I've never seen it.
Okay.
He was just sitting there.
They cut to it.
He's just like,
and I'm not even joking like what I just did.
You could sync that audio right up to what the fuck he's doing.
Literally like that.
I don't,
I gotta get into this fucking sport.
I don't understand.
Like I have,
I,
I lived through the 78 red sox.
Okay.
I lived through the fucking 85 bears,
crushing my patriots,
the 86 red sox.
Mets.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
I don't even fuck all Canadians when we can never beat the fucking Canadians.
All of those heartbreaking games,
uh,
the air and boom game,
all of that.
I never at the end of any of those losses when,
I mean,
what the Fuck Jesus Christ,
what point are you like,
I'm taking this too seriously.
He had just,
he was hopeless.
This fucking guy,
it was like,
okay.
It was like he just built his own house by hand.
He had,
he had this some country and he built a house by hand and he had to go back and
get his family and he finally got him and he goes,
this is the house that I built for you.
And then the whole fucking thing just collapsed.
Then I can understand standing there being like,
I can understand that you just watched the fucking sport where you can't even
use your hands.
And he was sitting there hands down by his side.
Oh,
that poor bastard.
That would have been the most uncomfortable feeling ever to give him,
to give him another man a hug like that when they're crying like that,
to just feel them collapse into you
first over a soccer game.
Oh,
I know.
It was the championship of the world.
Okay.
I get it.
All right.
I understand.
So,
uh,
anyways,
congratulations to the Germans.
I mean,
they clearly were the best team and I could say that with confidence because I
watched about,
you know,
collectively maybe about three hours of the World Cup.
Um,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
It seemed like it seemed like a good fucking game.
All right,
there you go.
That's the end of my riveting World Cup.
Oh,
by the way,
my apologies to Algeria for call new Albania all last week.
I hope I didn't fuck it up again.
Um,
okay.
Whatever.
Just know that I'd bet on you.
Okay.
Does that count as an apology?
Wow.
It gives a shit.
All right,
let's,
let's get onto some fucking for this week.
Oh,
Jesus.
Here we go again over the stamps.com everyone you know that feeling you get when
you can get things done with just the click of your mouse.
It can't get more convenient than that.
And now you can even get your mailing and shipping done without leaving your
desks desk.
Thanks to stamps.com stamps,
stock comp turns your PC or your Mac and to your own personal post office that
never closes.
Talk about convenient by in print,
official US postage for any letter or package using your computer and printer
and then just change your mail to the mailman or mailwoman or drop it in the
mailbox and you'll never have to go to the post office again.
I use stamps.com to send out all my DVDs,
my posters or whatever crap I'm selling at the end of my show.
I'm a moron if I can figure out how to use it.
So can you right now use my last name bur bur for this special offer,
it's a no risk trial plus a hundred $110 bonus offer that includes a digital
scale that calculates the exact postage for letters and packages and up to $55
free postage.
So don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
burr.
All right,
who's next?
Evil Loyce everybody,
if you take all your business calls yourself,
it's hard to look like a professional or to get anything done for that matter by
helping you expertly manage all your business calls.
He voice provides you with a better way to connect with your clients with a toll
free number,
professional voice greeting,
and a dial by name directory.
He voice transforms any phone into your business phone.
When your customers call,
they will automatically be sent to wherever you are.
You could be at home,
the office or sitting poolside with the cold beverage.
You'll always sound like a fortune 500 company.
You can get all of this for under 13 bucks a month.
That's right.
13 bucks a month for a limited time.
My listeners can try.
He voice for free for 60 days.
That is correct,
sir.
60 days.
But this extended trial will not last forever.
You have to do it now.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter the Promo Code Bill B I l l upon checkout to
get your special offer.
Make sure you hurry up because this offer will end soon.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com Promo Code Bill.
One more time.
[inaudible] dot Com Promo Code Bill.
All right,
back to the podcast here.
So [inaudible] uh,
what's going on with me?
Oh you know what's funny,
I have been talking to you guys for the last year and a half about the water
damage on my house.
So to get you updated,
okay.
She give a fuck.
My house is a 91 years old and what I quickly learned,
cause we were just going to fix the a the three little shit shack rooms do it
yourself.
A hunk of crap that was underneath my wife's office.
Um,
you know,
that's all we were going to fix.
But what happens is,
is when you have a house as old as mine and everybody who lived in it before,
you didn't do a fucking thing to it other than just maintain it.
Um,
when you go into the walls it's,
it's,
it's a shit show.
All right.
And what started off as just what I was going to do.
Basically my house was initially just a ranch was just a one floor thing and
then downstairs there was like a porch.
And throughout the years they added,
they dug into the hill I guess,
and they added this ground floor and it never really made sense.
Like he,
it seemed like an apartment downstairs in the house.
Upstairs,
there wasn't any flow.
So anyway,
so downstairs and there was like this going into the hill off of the,
the main room downstairs you'd walk up to stairs,
you'll open the door and then you are at this walk in closet to the left.
If you kept going straight,
there was another stair and then there was another little room at somebody at
some point was developing pictures back when people use film and Shit is really
creepy looking,
you know that that big tub where you fucking would throw the uh,
undeveloped pictures and look like you know,
something out of that serial killer show on showtime,
Dexter,
you know,
and then you went up one more step and then it was an unfinished area where you
could use for storage.
So all of that got all wet or whatever.
So they took all of that shit out and then dug out all the dirt and made it
level with the floor.
And I'm adding a real fucking bathroom down there and then a nice walk in
closet.
That's all I wanted to do.
Everybody,
that's it.
I got my hands up.
You know,
like when they call a file and you act like you didn't do it.
And I didn't touch him,
I didn't touch him.
All right,
so they go onto the walls and it is such an absolute shit show down there.
You know,
it's turned into an entire remodel of the downstairs and all the way through.
I have to get all the plumbing and all the electrical fixed on my house because
the walls and ceilings are open down there.
You might as well get it done.
I have all fucking galvanized pipe.
Okay.
And unknown Buster Keaton probably hauled the shit in while he was struggling in
Hollywood.
You know when this house was initially built and uh oh yeah,
the fucking electrical.
Jesus Christ.
I already had a guy one time
downstairs working on some electrical shit and I was upstairs watching TV or
something and I had the TV off.
I think I was in the TV room and I heard this guy downstairs and like three
times when he was down there trying to figure out why this switch,
these two,
the,
the why,
the outlet and the light.
We're on the same switch or something.
Like three times.
I heard him downstairs in the crawl space underneath where I was at.
I would hear what the fuck.
So what is a mess everybody.
And,
uh,
what was going to be this simple little project is now turned into an entire
just fucking remodel.
But I'm actually,
I've accepted it,
you know,
it's basically going to be like,
say you bought an old car and you just did a body off restoration.
So on top of you have the old carbon underneath,
you got to,
and not even a restoration at this point,
this going to be brand new shit.
So it's like you just went out and you bought state of the art chassis
suspension and all of that shit.
So,
uh,
I dunno,
I got to do it.
I got to Redo all the pipes and electric coke and then I eliminate the two major
things you don't want.
Okay.
Water flooding and a fire so I can leave town and not worry about that shit.
And,
um,
then all I got to worry about is the,
uh,
earthquakes,
mudslides and
yeah.
Fires and general out there.
Right.
Other than that,
I think I'm all set.
Oh,
Geez.
So I'm hoping the whole fucking thing's going to be done by the end of this.
Um,
so what I'm really trying to say is Billy boys got a lot of road dates coming
up.
Motherfucker.
You know,
it's always something I paid off the fucking thing,
right?
That's what I did.
That's what I did with everything that I've made.
I just throw it at my fucking house cause I know how this business ends.
The entertainment business does not end nicely.
Okay?
It ends with you sitting there with your hat and your hand goes,
oh,
what do you mean
for me?
You know,
I'm not going to be,
if I'm going to be there guy,
everybody's that guy.
But at the very least,
wherever I live is going to be fucking paid for.
So I paid the fucking thing off thinking I'm sitting pretty at throwing a
bathroom and boop a dude who gives a fuck.
And now it's just become,
I feel like I'm going to buy the whole house all over again.
You know,
it's an investment.
Buy a house.
It's a fucking investment.
Yeah.
Hold on,
I'm letting it go.
Letting it go,
letting it go.
It's going to be beautiful when it's done.
You know,
he's gonna make out in this,
whoever I fucking sell it to cause that that doesn't add value to your house.
Nobody gives a shit.
Oh,
should you see these copper pipes that are inside the walls?
No one gives a fight.
Gives a fuck about that.
You know,
buys the house the fucking way.
That's what it really comes down to.
Unless you're a single guy or a gay dude with your,
with your gay buddy.
Right.
And he'd come walking in,
you know when you look out the back yard and you try to see like,
you know what kind of pool party you can have or whatever the fuck it is they
look for.
You know,
I don't pretend to understand.
I don't pretend to speak for other groups,
although I do it all the time.
I guess women like a,
you know,
they come in,
Oh my God,
look at this kitchen.
I love her.
They love kitchens.
But then if he asks him to make a fucking for you,
they flip out.
It's like,
I thought you liked the kitchen.
Well,
I liked it to look at it,
bitch,
get out there and fucking puts on between two slices of bread now.
Or I swear to God,
I'm the lucky out on the porch.
You wouldn't dare.
I would.
And you don't know any UFC shit.
So I could pick you up right now and put you out there and there's nothing you
could do.
Yes.
Is You could scream rape,
you know,
on that ends all the fun,
doesn't it?
Don't you hate when that happens?
So anyways,
that's what's going on in my fucking world.
Uh,
oh.
By the way,
I've been getting a ton of shit on Twitter because of,
uh,
me talking about eating right and exercising.
I love how people call salads like rabbit food or they do that dumb shit.
We'll joke the cheese to and salad dressing.
You might as well have a burger at that point.
You know,
it's like,
first of all,
who doesn't know that?
And then secondly,
it's still not as bad as eating a fucking burger.
You asshole.
Okay,
I'll give a shit.
How much salad dressing you put on lettuce.
It's not going to lead the fucking heart disease.
All right?
Like a delicious juicy Goddamn Burger will.
All right.
You know,
you can't fucking help people.
I'm an old fuck people.
I'm 46 years old and I am.
I'm in the best shape.
I've been in a long time eating that way.
I just go with the balsamic.
You fucking negative con.
Some are yours.
Some he enjoyed the keen.
Why?
Salad recipes.
They're great.
Shovel it down your pie hole.
It will fill you up.
Stay away from the clown food and the fucking,
uh,
in the meats for a couple of days.
You do that twice a week,
twice a fucking week,
and just try the other five days.
You'd be amazed what happens.
Be Amazed what fucking happens.
Clown food,
by the way.
His desserts and I call it cloud food because when I'm,
when I'm using,
you know,
when I'm eating cookies and shit,
desserts look good to me.
But when I got that sugar craving anatomy,
and I'm not even looking at desserts,
when I glance over at the dessert tray,
that's literally what it looks like.
It looks,
it looks like that's what clowns would eat and that's why their face looks like
that,
you know,
whatever.
It makes sense to me,
you know.
All right here near I am bitch moaning and complaining about all this fucking
Shit and uh,
okay.
I'm going to ask you,
is there anybody who listened to this podcast that lives in Israel or lives in
Palestine?
Yeah.
I gotta ask you like how do you,
how do you fucking deal with,
yeah,
this Hatfield and McCoys shit that's going on over there.
I just look at it.
It's just at some point,
you know,
if you have the money,
why wouldn't you just fucking leave?
I swear to God,
I would just be all right.
You want it here,
take it.
Fuck it to yours.
Here it is.
This is the where the guy went with the sandals that everybody gives a shit
about.
You know,
doesn't got an op on all religions.
Doesn't God love everybody?
So why would he give a fuck where you lived if he made all of it?
But she made all of it or it made all of it.
If we crawled out of the fucking mud,
it's some point,
man.
Jesus Christ.
These fucking stories are heartbreaking.
They just shooting missiles at each other's towns.
Okay.
I don't have,
you know,
I don't know.
I get,
I'm trying to think if somebody was just shooting it at la.
What?
I leave you.
Yes.
Yeah,
go to Minnesota.
Okay.
It's fucking freezing.
Yeah.
Well there's nobody shooting a missile at me.
I don't,
you know,
obviously if you could tell by the way I'm speaking about it,
I'm ignorant as hell.
Like Israel,
they shot at this fucking police guys house.
They killed like 10 members of his family.
Yeah.
Now what is that going to do?
Is that going to make people on that other side,
you know,
hate less like,
oh,
now we get it.
Thank you.
Carry on.
You know,
I don't know.
What am I saying here?
Like look at,
look at World War Two.
What was,
was everybody in England supposed to just walk away?
But that Sarah entire country
at Jesus,
what am I suggestion here?
Suggesting?
Yeah.
I gotta be honest.
I,
I would fucking leave.
I just picture and that guy at the end of the Algeria game,
I would just,
that would have,
I would,
I just fight would have enough fucking you.
When you want it air,
it is fucking take it.
I'm out.
That's easy to say.
And then what?
You don't know the language.
You got to go somewhere else.
That's what I would do.
I would fucking build a concrete bunker and I would buy like as many Rosetta
stones as as I could afford and I would just try to learn other languages.
I just pick a fucking country and I would,
I would go there
and then what do you do?
I'm trying to think where I could live other than the United States
as a bunch of places.
I could look Canada,
I think I could live in England.
What else?
Definitely live in France.
Do you have a job is just take a while,
take a while to get used to it.
All those skinny jeans over there,
you know,
I dunno.
I think I just answered my question.
It's like where you're from,
where the fuck are you going to go?
You just accept it after awhile.
Jesus,
this is depressing.
Um,
all right,
let's get to,
uh,
how far into this podcast,
Darwin.
Oh,
foreign to this fucking book.
It's 35 minutes.
Okay.
I think it's time to read a couple of,
uh,
couple of,
letters for the week here.
Oh,
by the way,
uh,
I want to thank everybody who made all those Dj remixes of my,
my,
my attempt at imitating that music and that's all I was doing.
I wasn't saying it wasn't viable or anything like that.
If you really go back and listen to what I was saying,
I was just saying I'm glad to make it a bunch of money.
I hope they save it because I saw this same sort of bubble,
you know,
hair metal,
grunge,
boy bands,
standup comedy.
I've seen,
I've seen it over and over and over again.
So I hope they saved them money.
That's what I really was saying.
Really.
It wasn't a rant.
Um,
all right.
Although maybe it was,
I didn't really go back and listen to it.
All right.
Dj's.
Oh.
And if you want to listen to all of the,
uh,
all the Dj remixes from last week,
you can go on to Twitter.
We're going to have them all up there.
Um,
at the m m podcast is the Twitter handle.
I believe you say at the m M podcast.
Uh,
please follow this podcast there.
We'll have the links to all whatever the fuck I talk about the videos and
whatnot.
All right,
DJ's.
Hey Billy Bass,
drum greetings from Finland.
I'm a 20 year old musician and for the past few years I've been getting into
electronic music.
Before you call me a mouse head,
I don't give a fuck if you like that guy.
I don't hate that guy or one of his Dick Sucking groupies hear me out.
I wouldn't know the difference between his,
the mouse head looking guy or the other guy who looks like a one of the two
Coreys um,
about that ear rape.
You hear in mainstream clubs,
there are a number of Djs or whatever you want to call them,
who actually can play some real instruments.
I play guitar,
drums,
Bass,
and some piano.
It is true that a big part of making music on a computer is editing,
but when you record your own samples and start fucking around with them,
it is as time consuming and tedious as any form of music.
Okay.
You know,
you had me right up until then.
Well,
so is painting a house,
does that mean the guy painting the houses?
Hendrix.
Okay.
That doesn't make any sense to me,
sir.
Okay.
Listen,
I know that that what you're doing is an arc.
Okay?
I'm not,
you know,
I'm just,
I'm just making,
I just make fun of Shit.
Okay?
Don't,
don't get all fucking,
don't get any sadder than you are.
All right?
Don't add any more black clothing or eye liner to your fucking wardrobe,
Steve,
that's one of the stereotypes.
We don't do that anyways.
He says overrated.
Too much deodorant.
No sane person wants you to smell like nuclear waste.
Underrated.
I'm using the stairs.
I see way too many lazy fucks taking.
Okay?
Always taking the most convenient way.
If you've got a pair of functioning legs,
fucking use them.
You'll thank yourself later.
Anyways,
thanks for reading and I'm looking forward to seeing you in Helsinki again.
Hold on.
I'm looking forward to coming over there.
That's actually going to become a dangerous part of the world for me.
And people keep saying that I'm trashing djs.
I'm not.
Anyways.
You know what's funny?
Nobody ever thinks that they're part of the problem.
You know,
your music is ear rape.
What I make is this tedious is learning the oboe.
Beep,
boop,
boop.
Uh,
all right.
Thoughts from Atlanta a they ability,
red face.
Hope this message finds you reading the Monday morning podcasts,
uh,
reading it on time.
Ha Ha.
Realtime media.
It can be challenging.
This message is from the ATL slash hot Hotlanta.
I hated that.
I missed your show at the Tabernacle.
Love the venue.
Have never seen a comedy show there.
I have those seen the dead weather,
the ray contours,
the white stripes,
widespread panic,
the black keys and many,
many other great performing artists.
I'm glad you have turned.
You've been turned on to Alison Mosshart.
Oh yes.
She's the lead singer of uh,
uh,
the dead weatherman.
I was saying last week that she's a rockstar and this guy's a green saying yeah,
she is a true fucking rockstar.
Amazing.
Great back story on how she started working directly with Jack White after a
show at the Tabernacle while the rec rank contours over the fuck you say we're
playing with the kills Jack White saw her,
uh,
thought she was the shit.
Everyone knows it.
What Jack White though was the shit.
Everyone knows that if you don't then you need to crawl out of your cave and
rejoin society.
Okay.
Did I read that right?
I guess she was playing with the kills and was opening for Jack Whites band and
he saw her thought she was the shit and that's how they uh,
okay.
They got together.
I think that that's what the point was.
I apologize for my reading.
Um,
anyways,
she said I want to take a minute,
share a few thoughts with you.
I've been listening to your podcast for a little over a year now.
A few items I feel compelled to comment on.
Fat Shaming.
Thank you.
I've been very focused on my health over the last year and dropping off the
wagon for about two years.
It feels great.
Getting back in shape.
Your podcast is motivating and I'm typically listening to it while I'm working
out or while traveling on a plane or in a car being
stationary and reminding myself I need to work out.
Uh,
if you don't like the fat shaming,
then don't listen to the fucking program.
It's not like there's not a million other things to listen to.
Um,
yeah,
I think I do fat shaving with a twinkle in my eye,
right.
Anyways,
vegetarian food at Chinese and Thai restaurants.
So yeah,
I keep bringing that up.
Like if I Google Vegetarian restaurant there,
we show these Chinese and Thai restaurants.
He says the reason this shows up is these cuisines are great for vegetarians.
Uh,
if you go to a real Chinese restaurant,
not some American Chinese crap,
the food is way more focused on the vegetables and is actually quite healthy.
Ties a little harder to find healthy.
But there are generally are a few great options at Authentic Thai Restaurants,
Aka not mouth breathing mall food.
If you don't believe me,
next time you're in Atlanta or I'm in La,
I'll prove it to you.
Um,
um,
dude,
I believe you if we don't have to have a lunch date here.
Um,
anyways,
yeah,
I just,
you know,
one of my version of Chinese food is that,
you know that fucking food you eat and 10 minutes later you're hungry again.
That really unhealthy shit.
So I,
uh,
I really ought to look into that a little bit more I guess.
But,
um,
okay.
Anyways.
Oh,
I,
you know what I am,
I forgot to do,
I wanted to apologize to saw the World Cup fans cause some people get annoyed
with me trashing,
you know,
I just like fucking irritating you guys.
You know,
it's fun.
And I think in your heart of hearts,
it really bugs you that the United States doesn't give a fuck.
Okay.
About the World Cup.
And I know right now you're like,
oh,
fuck off.
But you know,
it's true.
Okay.
And I think in your heart of hearts you actually want to be an American,
don't you?
Okay,
come on.
You can have a standard sized about that.
Just being some fat.
Fuck on your way to a more like a Walmart.
Okay.
Listen to some country music with your fucking jaw hanging open.
Alright.
Some ill fitting hat
listening to some country guy rubbing your balls.
View no lack the south.
You can get the fuck out cause this is America and we ain't changing for nobody.
Right?
And then they start playing a violin and it makes you want to leap out of the
truck.
Come on.
You know we wouldn't want to do that for like a couple of weeks.
Yeah.
European stock.
Australia's stop coming.
Visiting here and visiting the coastal city.
See the real America getting the middle of it.
Get the fuck in hot land.
Go to some of our d e and F fuckin cities.
All right,
why don't you get it?
Why don't you go out there and do some of that shit?
Just fucking drive around.
Okay.
And I challenge you to walk into my maybe four Walmarts in the middle of nowhere
and not break down like that Argentinian guy.
Ooh.
All right.
Okay.
Was there any point to be made there?
I don't think there was.
Um,
all right.
Other instrument?
Uh,
dear Billy Coltrane,
you played drums and that's awesome.
You're a bonafide cool kid because I suck at drums.
All right,
I'll take daddy said,
but if you could play a second instrument and be a master of it,
uh,
what would you play?
Sorry,
guitar is not an option.
Why?
Why isn't it a fucking option?
Because you say so.
All right.
I'll roll with it.
You got to choose between his saxophone,
trombone,
flute,
a violin,
what should and what genre music would,
uh,
would you want to be the master of?
Thanks.
And go flute yourself.
Oh,
Jesus.
Jesus with the ponds over there.
Um,
if I a saxophone,
trombone,
trombone darted out,
trombones,
a Badass fucking and Smith.
When you're muted with the plunger and like trumpet.
Trombone.
Yeah.
What would I play?
I don't know either that New Orleans shit or like,
I like the trombone player in uh,
in James Brown's band.
Fred.
Fred who?
Bomp bomp bomp put the Burger de de de de de Right.
Whatever the fucking song doing it to death.
I can't remember the name of the song or did I tell you guys I found a fucking
killer.
James Brown.
Yeah.
A killer.
James Brown.
Like an a new version or a different take of a
okay.
Of I feel good.
You got to hear this shit.
Hang on a second.
Let me see if I can,
uh,
bring this up real quick.
James Brown right there.
Click on that.
Yeah.
This is how much of a fucking genius this guy is.
Where the hell is it?
Hot Pants.
Here it is.
Listen to this shit.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Tell me you can listen to that fucking 9,000 times in a row.
You've got to listen to that.
A whole song other than the bridge is the only thing that's sort of sounds like
the original version that just sounds like him fucking around trying to figure
out how he's going to do it.
Yeah,
it did get Gail.
Um,
yeah,
I would play trombone.
I also really liked the trumpet.
I feel like that's an unbelievably powerful instrument.
And my dad had a record when I was a kid,
Ted Heath and his orchestra,
uh,
swing as king.
Yeah.
And they had a couple of sections with where it was just a trumpet Solo or just
the horn section would kick in and the,
and it was,
you know,
fucking blue,
Yada Yada.
You share when you were listening to it,
if he had a nice high fi system back in the day there and a,
I remember the first time I went and I saw a big band alive.
I went to Berkeley and I think I told this story before I went to Berkeley and
it was
the,
uh,
the buddy rich band and buddy was,
he was gone by then.
Even gone probably like five,
six years.
So they just would have these all star drummers come in.
Okay.
And play with the band and I could not fucking believe.
Like a big band was basically it was four trombones,
four saxophones,
four trumpets.
And uh,
I mean these guys when they would just,
just fucking all of them but play 16 fucking people blowing on horns,
you fucking it blow your goddamn wood back man was unbelievable.
So I've always loved that kind of music.
Um,
yeah,
I dunno the shift that I'm listening to now,
like I got an a rental car a couple of weeks ago and I just decided I was going
to listen to the pop station so I could kind of know what was going on just
because as a comedian you got it.
Somehow it's your job to kind of know what's going on out there.
I'll show you act,
we'll really start feeling dated.
Like I mentioned a couple months ago when I use Brittany Spears is a reference
as like when I was talking about,
you know,
some young floozy and it bombed.
Like it got nothing in front of this younger crowd.
And then I had to be like,
wait a minute.
She's like a 32,
33 divorced mother of two or three kids at this point.
She's not 19 anymore.
Bill,
you know,
fucking 14 years has gone by since.
Oops.
Um,
AH,
put on some clothes.
You fucking whore.
But God bless you.
You made your money,
you made your money.
Fuck it.
Um,
what am I saying?
So yeah.
So that actually has led me into listening to all kinds of other fucking shit.
Plus I played drums,
you know,
as the hobby.
And uh,
so I've always liked,
uh,
I guess rap music.
I refuse to call it hip hop.
I'm too white to call it hip hop.
It just doesn't sound right coming up that rap music.
That sounds right coming out of my mouth,
but like a,
yeah,
I like,
uh,
what was the guy I've been listening to?
Little Wayne's new one,
rich as fuck.
I just really liked the drums in that.
And I also think he's fucking hilarious.
Well behind your back,
like nunchucks and that's fun.
Nope,
I find myself laughing when I'm listening to his shit.
He's also amazing,
you know,
fuck Dalkin let's do it all right enough with that shit.
So that's what I'm meant to.
And if I could,
yeah,
trombone.
I would love that.
If I had,
if I could be like Bill Murray in groundhog day,
I would master drums,
Guitar,
trumpet,
Trombone,
piano.
That would probably be it.
And uh,
maybe base,
I dunno,
you know what I,
there's a guy I actually follow on Youtube.
If you're a bass player,
this fucking guy's the shit.
Like he plays all the great fucking,
uh,
songs that have just unbelievable baselines from funk all the way to like,
you know,
cover shit that you should know if you play in a band like that song,
uh,
that eight,
six,
seven,
five,
three Oh nine,
he plays that shit and he's just a really,
he's a pro.
I'll,
I'll actually,
I'll that link up.
Uh,
we'll have it up on the Twitter,
the at the m m a podcast,
Twitter handle.
We'll have all of that shit up there for you.
Um,
so yeah,
that's basically what I would dip,
shut this fucking thing off.
Jesus Christ.
What did I do?
Please tell me I didn't fuck this whole podcast up.
Is that better?
Was I leaning on this thing forever?
Well I don't have time to fix it.
God dammit.
Some point I'm gonna make,
I'm gonna make this a professional operation.
All right,
let's get to the next little,
I guess the final one here.
Um,
tennis.
Oh by the way,
the flute,
the flute is the one fucking instrument that this just know there was,
there's no cool way to play that instrument.
You know,
they just isn't and I don't want to hear about Jethro Tull bid.
It is dope.
I know.
Want to hear it.
Um,
yeah,
the flute,
the Piccolo,
like those are,
those are great little add ons when you have an entire symphony.
Like that's like the curb finders for the,
uh,
you know,
I remember back in the day when you're like,
all right,
I've tinted the windows,
I have my vanity plate.
You know,
I got a,
yeah,
got fuzzy dice hanging from the fucking rear view mirror.
What,
what's the last thing you put curb finders on?
Cause she didn't want to damage your rims.
That's what a flu to like a Piccolo is.
I mean,
who would even risk,
there's no way somebody just plays the Piccolo like you.
You're definitely playing multiple fucking instruments and you like the utility
guy on the team like,
Hey,
we need you to play right field.
All right,
I'll play the fucking Piccolo.
Right?
Um,
all right.
Tennis.
Anyone dear Billy Agassi.
Ah,
this person says,
I've heard you mention anything.
I have never heard you mention anything about playing tennis.
It sounds to me like a sport.
You and the lovely Nia would enjoy your in your Jack Lalaine stage and health
seems to be important to you.
Tennis is a great workout and after playing a handful of times,
you can actually see yourself getting better.
In your case,
we wouldn't call them tennis whites.
We called them tennis,
pasty whites.
Hey,
every body,
that guy,
um,
what's your history with the sport ever?
Give it a go.
Yeah.
I grew up in the 80s the big tennis boom was in the 70s so you know,
the fallout of it was still there.
I still have an oversized fucking racket probably with cat guts strengths.
Um,
no offense Peta,
but that's the way they made them back then.
And maybe the nylon.
I have no fucking idea.
Um,
I like,
I love tennis.
I love watching it and that type of shit.
As far as running around I,
my back and Shin splints,
I'm not fucking doing that.
I,
I see,
you know those people who play those running around sports,
basketball and all of them.
You have,
you ever see those guys when they get to their thirties and into their forties,
and they're still fucking coming out there tape from the ankle all the way up to
their hip.
Your body was not designed to fucking do that.
Running around.
I play on a grass surface.
If they got a local,
a Wimbledon replica,
I'd fucking play on that shit.
Um,
you know,
it's funny.
So I got a tennis racket.
Like everybody,
I played a little bit,
um,
in the 80s with my buddies,
you know,
and we would talk all kinds of shit.
We go out there and we'd get drunk,
go down with the public court.
You know,
the one that had the cracks in it with the grass coming up and like no net,
see,
just tie a string across it and he'd be playing at night.
You'd be arguing if it went over under,
remember that Shit.
That's the way we'd play.
We had to great time.
And um,
so when I moved out and went to New York City,
you know,
when I was packing the vitals,
obviously the tennis racket didn't make it.
And I remember,
uh,
when one time I met this really,
really nice woman,
I wanted to go on a date and she was like,
she suggested blank tennis because she was nice,
you know,
rather than going and getting boobs.
And I was like,
yeah,
I've got a tennis racket.
And I liked her so much.
Actually had my parents mail me my tennis racket down through me and I went out
to Brooklyn and we played tennis
and she won.
And that was the end of that were low at them saying,
no,
the relationship lasts a little bit longer than that.
But yeah,
that's probably I,
I don't,
I'm not into that shit.
Yeah,
I'm not into a,
although I got to tell you one of the Brooklyn Bridge and I jogged across that
all the way back to my hotel and I was surprised that I had that kind of wind.
But I got back into skipping rope again,
David tell you guys,
this is the workout that I used to do back in the day.
I would,
uh,
I put on classic sports network before they got bought up by fucking ESPN and
um,
I would tape old fights or you know,
of de la Jolla.
He was the big guy back then.
Um,
you know,
if he had a nice 12 round fight,
I would,
I would record it and hopefully it went like nine,
10,
11,
12 rounds.
And then what I would do was when I would watch it during my workout and what I
would do is I,
when the boxes were fighting,
I would be skipping rope.
I would skip rope and I would be watching the fight.
And when they rested,
I would stop skipping rope.
And then,
uh,
when they started fighting again,
I was back on the,
on the,
on the rope.
And I would just try to just build myself up to see how many fucking rounds I
could get to and uh,
we really gained an appreciation for the kind of fucking shape that those guys
are in.
Cause you just sit in there jumping up and down.
We,
we,
they're actually trying to prevent somebody from beating the shit out of them
while they try and beat the shit out of them.
You know that if you have had a fight in your fucking life,
you know,
if nobody trains to have a bar fight,
it just fucking happens.
Do you remember that shit?
How,
when did you were after like the,
I mean how long has a bar fight last?
It's like under,
under,
usually under 30 seconds.
You hear the glass break and hear all the fucking shit.
If you actually cut out all the shit talk and,
and sue,
oh fuck,
you fuck her with the [inaudible].
If you want to cut out all of that shit and just get down to the fighting aspect
of it,
it's usually under 30 seconds.
And I swear to God like how hard you're breathing.
It is ridiculous.
And these guys are just 12 rounds of that shit.
It's just,
it's unbelievable.
Um,
so that's the kind of thing,
because I hate going to the fucking gym.
I hate to end cardio and all that type of stuff.
So,
um,
I always try to have something going on that I can do that just doesn't have me
staring at the clock and I feel like I'm in science class back in the day,
you know?
So,
uh,
so there you go.
That's one to grow on everybody.
Um,
I think I hit everything.
I might have to pull up a little bit short here.
Oh,
you know what?
I forgot the last advertising for this week is uh,
oh,
the wonderful,
the lovely,
the always lovely dollar shave club.
Everyone,
the big razor companies think we're stupid.
Everybody.
Every year they roll out some ridiculous shaving technology gimmick and expect
us to shell out the big bucks for it.
Do you really need a razor with a vibrating handle?
A roller pivot ball back scratcher,
egg timer,
laser point.
A corkscrew?
I know I don't.
All right,
and you don't.
Uh,
we were shaving just fine before any of that junk and I definitely don't need to
spend my hard earned cash on it.
If you are sick of being treated like a fool,
join the hundreds of thousand of smarter people who join the dollar shave
club.com revolution.
Dollar Shave Club delivers the best blades and grooming supplies for just a few
bucks a month,
month.
Their blades are better than the big shave companies for a fraction of the
price.
Personal experience as applicable.
Um,
my listeners can get started out@dollarshaveclub.com,
uh,
slash burr and hey,
if you already are a member,
you got to check out their new doc Dick Cavett Post,
uh,
post shave lotion,
Ms. No ours in that.
Sorry guys.
It's the purpose.
Perfect way to make peace with your face after the disruptive act of shaving.
By the way,
underrated,
underrated aftershave lotion.
You actually need a nice pre shave lotion and an aftershave lotion.
Trust me,
your face.
We'll love you forth.
Look at me.
I feel like I'm doing an old aqua velvet commercial.
Um,
so I would recommend that a stop getting ripped off by the big shave companies.
Join Dollar Shave club.com/bur bur r that's dollar shave club.com/bur bur are
there you go.
Alright.
Never have to buy razors again.
Well,
he got to buy him,
but then you don't have to go out to go buy.
You don't have to pay too much for him.
That's all I'm trying to say.
All right everybody.
I believe that that's the podcast for this week.
I had a wonderful time shooting a cheat with you.
Um,
what do I got coming up?
I got the,
uh,
the benefits.
All the information's up on bill bird.com.
I got it tonight.
Tomorrow.
It's a benefit to,
uh,
to help out starving children.
I will be a manning the lines spooning out food during the afternoon and I'll be
doing the show late at night.
I was going to be doing it with James Smith.
Uh,
unfortunately he's a little bit under the weather.
I hope he's feeling better soon.
So,
uh,
we got Paul,
don't say I'm from Jersey.
Versie is going to be opening and,
um,
it's going to be a great time.
It's for a great cause.
And later on this month I will be up doing the Montreal comedy festival,
going to be hosting one of the gala's,
bringing it on all the,
you know,
the new talent that's going to come along and will the industry forced me out of
the business.
Um,
anyways,
I'm very looking forward to that.
And other than that,
I'm not doing shit other than spending all my money on the ground floor of my
fucking house.
All right,
everybody,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
Have a great week.
I'll talk to you next time.
All right.
Bye.